Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome to, uh...
ZenBlade?
The game where you slice up fruit with a sword.
Or at least that's what I think it is. There's only stuff
right in front of me that is sword. And fruit.
And I'm gonna slice! Oh!
Look at that! Oh.
That's so... Woah uh da hah oh
Ha!
Oh, shit. It is Fruit Ninja.
Wah! Oh...
Hi-yah! (laughs)
Ah! Oh jeez, my face.
Ha! Swa-swah!
Whoops. Uh...
Boink. Boink.
Hehehehe.
Oh, shit. Ahhhh!
This literally is just Fruit Ninja, but it's so cool!
Not that.
Got that.
Hwah ah!
Woah, shit.
Eh, uah!
Hi-yah. Ha!
Ha, who-ah-hah
Oh, this is so cool!
Hang on, I need to put this outta the window... Woah!
(babbles like a baby)
(orgasm-like moans)
Slay!
Oh, slay!
Slay, slay.
Slay. Slay.
(deeper) Slay.
Slay.
(soft) Slay.
Slay. Slay!
Oh, stay away. Slay.
Yes! Yes!
Yes, yes!
Yes, yes.
Yes.
Yes!
Yes! I love this, this is so cool.
(buzzer sound)
No!
Uh oh. Well, that sounds like bad.
Oh, that was cool.
Where did my other one go?
Eh, who cares?
I care if I'm gonna step on it. Where'd it go?
Where'd it go?
Where'd it go? Ah, shit.
Oh, boy...
Well, this ain't any kind of good...
Fuck, where'd it go?
I could take my headset off, that'd be... Smart.
Oh, it's over there. We're good.
We're fine!
Okay, so I'm gonna put the strap on.
Because it's gonna end badly for me.
This is one of those games that are
gonna get me out of breath. Ah, fuck!
I didn't mean that one.
Time Trial, I don't want that!
Sounds like a load of ... Bitch-ishness.
Eh.
I'm already an expert.
You can give me more advanced ones.
Eh,
Ooh! Okay.
(orgasm-like sounds)
Heh heh.
Heh. You thought you knew me.
Ah. You killed my father.
I'm here to kill you back.
(screeches like a majestic bird)
Hwah, hweah.
Doink!
Whoops.
YAAAAAASSS!
It's so cool.
Ha! OH!
(Slicing sound effects)
Hwah!
Yes!
Yeah! Yeah! Oh, God.
It really, I jus- Fuck!
I mean, I know it's just Fruit Ninja, but...
Hwah hwah hwah!
Seeing it in VR like this is kind of nuts.
Woah, did that hit me in the face?
Hit me in the dick, maybe?
Hwah! Ho!
Shit. Woah, this is getting nuts.
Ha hahh! Atah!
Whoops.
Atah! Wahtah!
WATAH!
Hwaa wata!
(Continued ninja/screaming noises)
(Mark making sword swishing sounds)
Slay! Slay! Slay! Slay! Slay! Slay! Slay! Slay slay! Slay!
Slay! Slay-lay-lay!
YEAH!! I did bad.
Oh man, I hit six of 'em? Son of a bitch.
Well, that ain't good!
I got to number 1898.
That's probably good.
(deep) Probably good.
*Arnold Schwarzenegger*
Oh swaoh!
Woah, son of a bitch!
(grunts)
Haoh!
It-it bugged out on me.
That wasn't my fault.
Okay. I'm ready for you.
Hah!
What the fuck!
Ah! Fyah.
(Making blade slicing sounds)
Ah, fuck! Ah, fuck! Ah, fuck!
I can do this. I know I can do this.
I can do this.
I let my inner peace go through me.
This is like the training I had in the
Himalayan ... Mountains as a child.
I had to carve my own sword
out of just my baby teeth.
And I used that as a club because
I was too stupid to actually use it like a sword.
I thought, I thought we -- Oh, shit.
I thought we were just hitting things.
I'm about to unleash my jitsu. Jutsu.
Jit -- I'm about to unleash my van... Aw, fuck.
You tiny watermelon. You don't deserve to—I would explode you with rubber bands.
Did it get it? Oh, come on!
Just fall already!
Why did I try to catch that?
I really did. I really tried to catch that.
That was weird.
Hwah
That's tiny! Ah, it's tiny!
What the fuck! I didn't even see it!
You gonna put tiny ones in front of me?
(yells in anguish)
Slay...
If you hit it with even slightly
the flat of your blade –
– it will just knock it up against...
Woah. Woah.
Oh, shit.
Fuck, I didn't see it.
Goddamnit, I didn't see it!
Fucking fuck.
127, 252.
I can do better than that.
I know I can do better than that.
I know I am better than that.
(distorted) I'm a hundred (unintelligible)
(unintelligible)
This is probably one of the
coolest VR- uses of VR I've seen.
Because it implements pretty much
everything that I like about VR.
Which is the immersion, one. The free roaming movement that I have in the other ones –
– and, three, the hand-eye coordination
that needs to be one-to-one to be true.
And this offers all of that. Like a hundred percent. It offers everything that I like out of the experience –
– and it also is a really cool test of skill.
Like obviously it's not a real test of skill.
If there were really this much fruit –
– I'm pretty sure the World Hunger Organization
would have some words to say to me.
Because of all the waste for my training.
But I wanna be a Super Saiyan so badly.
If I'm gonna get a new power level,
I need to slice this goddamn fruit for Goku!
'Cause he eats a lot!
Nyeh!
Because that is what, like ... Look!
Woah! Ah, fuck you. Ah fuck off!
(high-pitched) Oh, fuck off!
(screaming) I'm doing so good!
And then I lose it at the end there,
because there's a... Fuck! You!
Bitch.
Good thing I wore comfortable clothes for this, otherwise I'd be sweating up my jeans
and stinking up my whole room.
Not that my room doesn't stink already.
It's a mixture of dog and man-funk.
Which comes from me, not Chica.
She's a lady.
But she stinks.
(sharp quick breathing)
Hwah!
Woah!
That was almost bad.
Fuck. That was really hard.
Better than hitting a bomb, though.
I'll take that one.
Okay.
"Ho-kay. So here's da Earth".
"Round!".
Woah. Shit.
Oh, God. That was close.
Oh, shit. Woah. Fuck!
I didn't hit that bomb!
God damnit. 165.
I knew I could've done better. I didn't hit that!
Fuck!
I must take my aggression out on more fruit!
Must kill more fruit!
Must revenge family
who was murdered by fruit!
Oh, boy. It's my weakest erection.
That's just a joke. I don't have a weak erection.
All my erections go in one!
No time for jokes!
Shit.
(no time for commentary either)
Okay.
Oh, boy.
(buzzer) x3
What? Oh, fuck, man!
19!
Is that good? I don't know!
I don't know how long I've been playing, guys.
I don't even know if something
went wrong with the recording.
I think I've been going about two hours,
but I'm not a hundred percent certain.
Haven't been talking this entire time.
I've been unbelievably focused
on just perfecting my holding style.
But also keeping it away from my body,
because there were some tracking bugs.
I mean, mostly it was just me missing.
I will readily admit that that was a problem.
But there are some tracking bugs.
If the position gets offset by an inch –
– there's gonna be, obviously, a little problem.
It's gonna skirt to the side and maybe knock it around.
And also a consistency of slice ...
In terms of speed, is necessary.
The speed can't be too fast.
Or else you're gonna get another tracking bug –
– where the Vive can't keep position of your hands.
And then it'll jut around because ... It is like that.
Sorry. Concentrating.
Anyway, I'm just trying to get the high score.
Yes, this is taking this much effort. God.
Oh, my arm is really tired, guys.
Woo, boy. Oh my god.
Ah, muscles burning! I'm outta shape!
Wah, shit.
Okay ... Keep it up. Okay.
Okay.
Okay...
Fuck!
Oh, the pain ... Is rather immense!
Golly shitbags.
Holy fuck my a-noos.
Good god. Oh my god.
Oh, fuck me.
Fuck...
Ow.
Oh my god.
Fuck!
Okay! I broke 200.
Oh, and my ... Oh my god.
I also realized recently that
I got 4th on the Daily Leaderboard.
And then I'm 20th ... Overall.
Man...
Oh, man...
I've been playing this a long time ... A long time.
Holy shit.
Oh, wow. I gotta take this off.
Holy crap.
Ow, man.
Let me check how long I've been...
Ah, that doesn't say...
That was ... An adventure.
I don't even know what time it is.
I feel like I woke up in a different universe.
Holy shit.
I've been playing that for
two and a half hours.
Wow! So...
That is really fun!
I did pretty good.
And then I got obsessed
with victory so much that I kept playing.
And my arm and shoulder just started
getting more and more tired –
– and then started hurting really bad on that last one.
But I broke 200!
Which is a good place to stop on.
So, thank you everybody
so much for watching.
I'm probably gonna play this on my own.
If you wanna see another video of it, I'm gonna try for the number 1, or at least the Top 10 on the leaderboard.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching!
And let me know what other VR games
you want me to play in the future.
And thanks again.
And as always,
I will see you ... In the next video!
Bye bye!
Was that impressive?
Probably not.
WOLOLOLOLOLO